und wir erwarten ihr statement zum
treffen
lieber lasten ich freue mich sehr dass
du heute nach berlin gekommen bist die
vorzeichen eines besuches in die lage in
europa sind sehr sehr ernst umso größer
meine freude die ich heute hier begrüßen
zu können
da du kommst du aus lettland kanadische
truppen leisten dort einen wichtigen
beitrag um das bündnisgebiet zu
verteidigen deutsche soldaten stehen im
nachbarland litauen um die aus planken
der nato abzusichern wir sind dankbar
dass unsere transatlantischen
verbündeten hier einen so wichtigen
beitrag für die sicherheit in europa
leisten
der angriff russlands auf die ukraine da
sind wir uns einig markiert eine
zeitenwende
für europa aber auch für die
friedensordnung der russische angriff
auf die ukraine ist ein eklatanter
völkerrechts bruch und die welt in der
wir leben ist jetzt nicht mehr dieselbe
wir sehen jetzt viele angriffe auf
ukrainische städte und schulen und
wohnhäuser das leid der bürgerinnen und
bürger der ukraine der menschen im
kriegsgebiet macht uns alle fassungslos
was wir jetzt brauchen ist eine
waffenruhe und wanda appell auch an den
russischen präsidenten ist stoppen sie
das blutvergießen ziehen sie die
russischen truppen zurück es ist eine
schlimme katastrophe für das ukrainische
volk aber auch das russische volk leidet
an diesem krieg
wir brauchen jetzt einen
waffenstillstand und dass wir ein ende
des waffengangs brauchen dass er zum
ende kommen muss darüber habe ich mich
auch unterhalten mit meinem
französischen kollegen emanuel makro und
dem gespräch das sich mit dem
chinesischen präsidenten geführt habe
das ist doch für alle klar eine
militärische lösung des konfliktes macht
keinen sinn das was wir jetzt brauchen
diplomatische lösung und darum bemühen
wir uns auch eng abgestimmt mit unseren
internationalen partnern und wir hoffen
dass es lösungen gibt in den gesprächen
zwischen der ukraine und russland und
dass wir einen weg finden können der aus
dieser situation heraus hilft was wir
tun ist unsere hilfe zu leisten die ist
bekannt im übrigen ist es so dass der
das premier trio und ich uns einig sind
dass wir überall wo das möglich ist
nicht einfach zum tagesgeschäft
übergehen insbesondere der
internationalen organisation und deshalb
ist ein ganz besonderes zeichen dass die
generalversammlung der vereinten
nationen ziemlich einhellig das vorgehen
russlands in dieser angelegenheit
verurteilt hat den angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine verurteilt hat die
weltgemeinschaft wird dieses vorgehen
nicht hinnehmen und sich damit auch
nicht abfinden das ist entscheidend und
das müssen auch alle die jetzt diesen
krieg vorantreiben immer wissen
wir haben uns hier unterhalten nicht nur
wird den krieg und wie wir gemeinsam
zusammen stehen auch um die menschen in
der ukraine zu beschützen mit den
möglichkeiten die wir haben sondern auch
über die langfristige entwicklung
unserer welt und spielt für unsere
beiden länder die klimapolitik eine ganz
ganz zentrale rolle sie ist auch wichtig
und zentral wenn es um die prioritäten
der deutschen g7 präsidentschaft gibt wo
kanada und wer als gleichgesinnte
partner seite an seite agieren was wir
gerne wollen ist dass das glas kogler
mit dass aggression kleine packt
umgesetzt wird und wir wollen auch alles
dafür tun dass die weltgemeinschaft
zusammenarbeitet deshalb treiben wir das
projekt eines internationalen klima
clubs voran indem länder die auf
unterschiedliche weise vorangehen um die
co2 emissionen zu reduzieren und eine
co2 neutrale welt zu schaffen wird die
zusammenarbeit trotz der
unterschiedlichen wege ich bin sehr
dankbar dass kanada des studios sind
dabei ein enger bündnispartner liste mit
wir diese dinge voranbringen können es
geht ja darum dass wir mit diesen klima
club auch die harmonisierung unserer
mögen hinkriegen auch in der frage von
co2 preise und spielt das eine große
rolle
deshalb bin ich auch die ja sehr dankbar
für deine co2 bepreisung initiative das
ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger vorschlag
den glasgow vorgestellt hast und wir
jedenfalls werden das unterstützen
natürlich stellt sich die frage wie
kriegen wir unsere ehrgeizigen
klimapolitischen ziele umgesetzt nochmal
zur erinnerung deutschland will schon
bis zum jahr
2045 dass es im knapp 25 jahren
klimaneutral wirtschaften als eines der
erfolgreichsten
industrieländer der welt ist das eine
große herausforderung
es geht um das heizen es geht um
mobilität aber es geht eben auch um die
industriellen prozesse die den größten
teil des energieverbrauchs in unseren
ländern ausmachen und die wir deshalb
auch entsprechend umstellen müssen und
da sind wir uns einig dass es wichtig
ist dass wir diesen weg gehen indem wir
setzen auf den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien auf windkraft offshore und
onshore kanada noch andere möglichkeiten
mit wasserkraft dass wir die
solarenergie fördern und zu stärken und
dass wir eng zusammenarbeiten bei der
nutzung von wasserstoff
für uns ist wichtig dass wir in dieser
frage eine enge kooperation auf den weg
bringen und genau das haben wir uns
miteinander vorgenommen dass wir alles
dafür tun dass für die wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit unserer länder
wasserstoff den wir gerne auch aus
kanada beziehen wollen eine zentrale
rolle spielt und wir werden dabei auch
die frage der rohstoffe mit dem blick
nehmen denn auch bei uns geht es jetzt
darum zu diversifizieren woher wir die
wichtigen rohstoffe für unsere industrie
bekommen und dabei geht es natürlich
auch um die diversifizierung in den
fragen die für uns wichtig sind wenn es
jetzt um gasimporte geht nach
deutschland da brauchen wir mehr
alternativen gut dass diese auch
gleichzeitig die struktur sein können in
der wir langfristig eine wasserstoff
wirtschaft aufbauen können so ist das in
deutschland geplant das ist wenn ich es
richtig verstehe auch der weg den kanada
geht bin also sehr froh dass wir unsere
vielen begegnungen um eine weitere
ergänzen können die ja auch schon
angefangen haben lange bevor ich
bundeskanzler geworden bin und dass wir
sie fortsetzen können unsere bemühungen
für eine welt die besser zusammen hält
die soziale ist gerechter ist die aber
gleichzeitig auch in der lage ist die
große auf gebäude des menschengemachten
klimawandels zu lösen und jetzt ganz
aktuell geht es natürlich um den frieden
das haben die menschen verdient die
jetzt unter den bomben leiden und die
wir schützen müssen
guten tag ich freue mich sehr hier sein
zu können vielen dank kanzler scholz für
den herzlichen empfang
aber ich möchte ihnen auch direkt danken
für ihre grossartige führungsrolle in
dieser schwierigen zeit
dieser starke haltung zu sanktionen und
strafmaßnahmen gegen wladimir putin und
den kreml für ihr absolut abscheulich
verhalten oder ob es um die
unterstützung für die ukraine geht es
war eine freude mit ihnen
zusammenzuarbeiten und sicherzustellen
dass wir stark reagieren auf diese
bedrohung nicht nur die bedrohung
unserer freunde sondern auch die
bedrohung der demokratie an sich ich
freue mich sehr hier auch so viel mit
unserem chef minister eine seite zu
haben und unseren und ihre
außenministerin unsere außenminister
pardon und die treffen und diskussion
zwischen uns waren sehr wirksam und
fruchtbar deutschland und kanal kanada
stehen seite an seite gegen die invasion
putins eine bedrohung der demokratie der
sicherheit und des friedens in europa
und weltweit
heute vormittag habe ich mit präsenzen
gesprochen ich habe einmal mehr betont
welcher stärke und entschlossenheit das
ukrainische volk sich wehrt und bald auf
hochspezialisierte
ausrüstungsgegenstände aus kanada
rechnen kann und
rechne damit dass kanada das kanadische
parlament das gut heißt kanada freut
sich seite an seite mit deutschland das
syrische volk zu unterstützen wir sind
dabei auch die nato zu stützen und zu
stärken es sind sehr strenge sanktionen
ergriffen worden
und heute kündige ich 50 millionen
dollar zusätzlich an um
militärausrüstung in die ukraine zu
schicken und 15 millionen verlangen und
das ganze noch mal auf englisch
gibt aber noch eine größere
herausforderung als die ukraine an sich
so es geht um schutz und verteidigung
unserer demokratien das ist da geht es
um den kampf gegen
desinformation wir müssen
zusammenarbeiten um demokratie die
demokratie für alle zu verteidigen in
unseren ländern ich kann also heute
ankündigen dass kanada die den g7
mechanismus
bestätigt der in schalke vor vier jahren
in kanada zum ersten mal geschlossen
wurde und da geht es um die
zusammenarbeit zwischen ländern die des
informationskampagnen und einfluss
kampagnen ausländischer mächte
ausgesetzt sind hier so geht es um die
untergrabung der demokratie gegen die
wir uns werden müssten und wir haben
weitere drei millionen dollar
bereitgestellt zum kampf gegen die des
informationskampagnen aus russland wir
müssen ein stehen für wahrheit gegen
desinformation mit der wir in die irre
geführt gespalten werden sollen die
krise in der ukraine zeigt auch wie
wichtig die energiesicherheit ist und
vision wichtig die beschleunigung hin zu
grünen wirtschaft ich habe mit ganzer
stolz darüber gesprochen wie wir sie
verstehen die verbindungen zwischen
deutschen und kanadischen
investoren stärken können insbesondere
im bereich der wasserstoffwirtschaft
es geht um fortschritte bei der
batterietechnik
spitzentechnologien wir brauchen dafür
sichere und residente lieferketten
kanada und deutschland stehen seite an
seite in unserem
ehrgeizigen ziel net zero zu erreichen
also null co2 bisherige wollen die
wirtschaft grün wachsen lassen und gute
arbeitsplätze schaffen und
karrieremöglichkeiten auf beiden seiten
des atlantik wir arbeiten mit
deutschland zusammen um die co2
bepreisung weltweit zu voranzubringen
und wir rufen alle dazu auf sich dem
klima club von ganzer stolz
anzuschließen geht es geht um die
zukunft unserer kinder und enkelkinder
um saubere luft und bessere chancen für
die generation nach uns
werde ich in polen sein um dort die
situation die flüchtlingskrise zu
besprechen kanada wird weiter mit
partnern in europa zusammenarbeiten um
die demokratie zu verteidigen um die
ukraine zu unterstützen und um eine
sichere und
prosperierende zukunft für alle zu
gewährleisten vielen dank
eine frage von der global
premierminister trikot sie haben sich
auf ihre gespräche für sensor lenski
bezogen haben versprochen mehr sonder
ausrüstungen zu schicken
das können sie dazu sagen was es wie
denn die kanadische unterstützung über
die grenze kommen soll und was können
sie seien zu den hilfsleistungen
wir haben eine reihe von
spezialgeräten bereitstellen können zum
beispiel kameras in drohnen die wir in
den nächsten tagen in die ukraine
schicken werden wie sie wissen gibt es
da probleme an der grenze wie können wir
also diese ausrüstung sicher in
ukrainischer ende bringen aber wir
arbeiten mit partnern zusammen um das
problem zu lösen mit all unseren
verbündeten die also die logistischen
herausforderung bewältigen können die
natürlich real sind aber nicht
unüberwindlich wir liefern mehr und mehr
hilfsleistungen und
wir haben die möglichkeit die so weiter
zu tun wir haben
kamen da der kameras aus kanadische
produktion
beschafft die bei der verteilung des
landes helfen sind spezialkameras für
drohnen und wir werden in den kommenden
tagen
schicken und wir hoffen auch noch mehr
hilfslieferungen über die grenze bringen
zu können trotz der schwierigkeiten der
wir uns bewusst sind aber wir haben alle
notwendige unterstützung unserer
verbündeten um diese hilfe für die
ukraine bereit stellen zu können
ist aus ihrer sicht eine lieferung von
mit kampfflugzeugen aus polen an die
ukraine jetzt endgültig schon vom tisch
mit dem neuen der usa und herr scholz
wäre deutschland grundsätzlich bereit so
was zuzulassen oder fürchten sie dass
deutschland zum beispiel durch eine
nutzung von rammstein zu sehr in den
militärischen konflikt rhein gezogen
würde
sie wissen geht es um finanzielle hilfen
die wir schon viele jahre auf den weg
gebracht haben um die residenz der
wirtschaft der ukraine zu stärken das
haben wir jetzt in der krise auch weiter
fortgeführt es gibt große finanzielle
unterstützung wir haben humanitäre
leistungen auf den weg gebracht wir
haben auch alle möglichen
ausrüstungsgüter zur verfügung gestellt
und wie sie wissen auch einzelne waffen
über die wir sie informiert haben und
ansonsten ist es aber so dass wir sehr
genau überlegen müssen was wir konkret
tun und dazu gehören ganz sicherlich
keine kampfflugzeuge
wir werden weiter
ausrüstungsgegenstände und waffen
schicken wie sie benötigt werden über
das in kanada bisher getan habe müssten
seite an seite mit unseren partnern
vorgehen und müssen aufpassen dass wir
nicht zur eskalation beitragen wollen
den konflikt deeskalieren und beenden
und wir sind da um die ukraine auf alle
erdenkliche weise zu unterstützen aber
wir müssen uns schauen auf wie das auf
bestem wege geschehen kann
heide quatschen für baut er eine frage
an sie beide zur energiepolitik wir
wissen dass deutschland immer noch sehr
abhängig ist von russischem öl und gas
wir wissen dass kanada viel öl und gas
hat aber das nicht so leicht nach europa
schaffen kann haben sie darüber heute
gesprochen gibt es eine art von energie
partnerschaft die denkbar ist zwischen
ihren ländern und gibt es irgendetwas
das sie gerne kurz oder langfristig
tun möchten um kanadische energie durch
kanadische energiequellen die russischen
zu ersetzen wir hatten lange
diskussionen darüber kanada hat
natürlich ein ziemlich starken
energiesektor mit tausenden von toten
kanadischen arbeitsplätzen sie hart
daran arbeiten energieversorgung zu
sichern während wir gleichzeitig an dem
übergang zu co2 0 an dem übergang zu 20
arbeiten es gibt jetzt natürlich
probleme durch den konflikt mit russland
und bei den erhöhten bedarf an gas und
öl
wir haben darüber gesprochen wie wir
nicht nur kurz und mittelfristig da eine
partnerschaft eingehen können bei der
energie stellen wie vor aber bei jedem
schritt achten wir darauf dass wir den
übergang hin zu erneuerbaren und
sauberen energien schaffen wollen darauf
hat dazu bekennt sich kanada und
deutschland und wir alle müssen das tun
wir müssen gemeinsam daran arbeiten uns
gibt sehr viele chancen für
partnerschaften um dieses thema
wir wissen das ja kanada sehr viele
ressourcen in fossilen energieträgern
hat und wir sind darum auch zu helfen
wenn dies erforderlich ist denn das ist
eine industrie mit sehr guten
arbeitsplätzen in kanada die nicht nur
in den traditionellen energie bereichen
arbeiten sondern auch an der innovation
für zukunftslösungen das ist keine
lösung für morgen sondern für
mittelfristige veränderungen und der
arbeiten wir zusammen dran um
einen robusten weg zu entwickeln hin zur
dekarbonisierung unserer
volkswirtschaften im wissen dass die
situation mit russland die dies
gleichzeitig komplizierter aber auch
dringend notwendig macht
kanada und deutschland verfolgen die
gleichen ziele wenn es darum geht eine
klimafreundliche industrie zu erreichen
und beide länder sind sehr sehr
ehrgeizig wir sind erfolgreiche
wirtschaftsnationen die auch intensiv am
globalen handel teilnehmen und trotzdem
sind wir uns sehr klar darüber dass wir
auch eine aufgabe haben die weit über
uns selber hinausreicht denn die
techniken die lösung die wir entwickeln
sind wenn sie global wettbewerbsfähig
sind zugleich auch technik und lösungen
die in vielen anderen der welt dann
ländern der welt dann später eingesetzt
werden können weil wir gezeigt haben
dass es geht und weil wir die
möglichkeiten
herausgefunden haben die man nutzen kann
das gilt insbesondere für die nutzung
von wasserstoff denn wenn wir in
kürzester zeit deutschland ich habe
schon gesagt mit 2045 co2 neutral
wirtschaften wenn wir in kürzester zeit
das erreichen wollen dann werden wir
dazu erhebliche zusätzliche mengen an
elektrizität brauchen die wir offshore
onshore mit solarenergie und mit unserem
starken stromnetz erzeugen aber wir
werden eben auch in großem maßstab
wasserstoff nötigen dass ein teil der
heute genutzten fossilen ressourcen
ersetzt dieser wasserstoff wird in
deutschland produziert werden aber
wahrscheinlich überwiegend aus anderen
ländern importiert werden und das ist
der eine anknüpfungspunkt für eine sehr
intensive strategische zusammenarbeit
zwischen kanada und deutschland weil wir
genau verstehen dass kanada ein land ist
das uns helfen kann bei der dem import
von wasserstoff der dann auch
klimafreundlich in wasserstoff in kanada
produziert wird im übrigen gilt das
nicht nur für wasserstoff sondern auch
für viele rohstoffe die wir jeden tag
für unsere story brauchen auch jetzt
jeden tag und natürlich ist es
naheliegend dass wir uns mit der frage
beschäftigen wie wir die mittel und
kurzfristigen probleme lösen können die
entstehen wenn wir unsere
energieversorgung diversifizieren wollen
die ja in der übergangsphase auch noch
fossile ressourcen nutzt das ist eine
aufgabe die eben umso einfacher zu
bewältigen ist und so mehr man die
langfristige perspektive gleichzeitig
mit dem blick hat wahrscheinlich sind
kanada und deutschland mit die
ehrgeizigsten denn dass das den kampf
gegen den klimawandel betrifft und
deshalb ist eine solche partnerschaft
eine enge zusammenarbeit in all diesen
fragen sehr nahe liegt wir jedenfalls
werden uns jetzt erstmal terminals zu
legen an der nordseeküste die unsere
möglichkeiten der versorgung verbessern
und langfristig wird werden diese
terminals genutzt werden für wasserstoff
ja eine anschlussfrage die wissenschaft
geht davon aus dass deutschland auch
kurzfristig ohne russische energie
auskommen könnte die wirtschaft geht
davon jetzt erstmal nicht auf see ist
ihr nein dazu russische energie
einbahnen darauf zu verhängen ist das
kategorisch oder sehen sie da unter
welchen umständen könnten sie sich
vorstellen dass man die energiezufuhr
nach deutschland reduziert wir sind uns
mit unseren partnern ganz besonders auch
mit unseren transatlantischen partnern
also kanada und den usa völlig einig
dass die abhängigkeit von fossilen
rohstoff importen europas ganz anders
ist als die abhängigkeit etwa die usa
oder kanada die usa sind zur exporteur
von
gas und öl zum beispiel das kann man für
europa insgesamt nicht sagen und deshalb
sind die dinge die getan werden können
auch unterschiedlich und alle wissen
dass wir kurzfristig herausforderungen
haben sie bewältigen müssen wenn es zum
beispiel dazu kommt dass die
wirtschaftlichen kooperationen in diesem
bereich dass die wirtschaftlichen
beziehungen in diesem bereich nicht mehr
funktionieren wie sie über viele jahre
und jahrzehnte funktioniert haben und da
gibt es viele technische fragen zu lösen
die sich nicht mit einer mathematischen
modellrechnungen ersetzen lassen das
wissen alle praktiker jedenfalls ganz
genau trotzdem widmen wir uns diesem
thema und was vielleicht für sie eine
gute und beruhigende information ist
nicht erst seit kurzem ich habe schon im
dezember mit allen diskutiert wir müssen
uns auf die situation
vorbereiten dass es kompliziert werden
wird und haben damit angefangen deshalb
wissen wir aber auch genau wie
kompliziert es ist
ja so weit also die pressekonferenz des
bundeskanzlers mit seinem amtskollegen
justine otto nach wie vor bei uns im
studio ist professor stephan fröhlich
was auffällt neben dem hauptthema dieser
pressekonferenz wie groß die rolle war
die die gemeinsamen anstrengungen von
kanada und deutschland betreffen den
klimawandel zu begrenzen
das ist es richtig das war aber
vielleicht nicht in dem umfang aber es
war erwartbar dass es auf jeden fall
thematisiert würde in der tat der
kanzler hat gesagt standen hier
gewissermaßen die die musterschüler
zusammen gemeinsam vor der kamera was
den klimaschutz anbelangt die
selbsternannten wie wir gerade gehört
haben das wird teilweise natürlich
unterschiedlich bewertet aber dass wir
und kanada zu den treibenden kräften
gehört auch auf internationaler bühne
das ist überhaupt keine frage insofern
war es erwartbar und natürlich gibt es
die brücke hin zu dem thema
energiesicherheit das ja untrennbar
verbunden ist uns alle im moment
beschäftigt im zusammenhang mit kriegen
der ukraine so dass das geradezu
zwangsläufig war und dass die beiden
sich das nicht nehmen lassen würden
darüber zu reden war auch ziemlich klar
gut kommen wir zum thema ukraine das
natürlich im mittelpunkt dieses
gesprächs stand wir hier in deutschland
die nato mitglieder können sich
einigermaßen sicher fühlen weil es
dieses beistands versprechen der nato
gibt und zu diesem beistands versprechen
der nato gehören eben nicht nur die
anderen europäischen nationen sondern
auch die usa und kanada insofern ist es
von hoher symbolischer bedeutung das
trio jetzt nach europa kommt nicht nur
nach deutschland was ja vielleicht nicht
so bedroht ist aber eben auch nach
estland und nach polen geht um zu
ermauern das was auch joe biden gesagt
hat jeder ins nato gebiet wird
verteidigt auch von kamera auch von den
usa ja das ist richtig wobei wir
natürlich gleich korrigieren müssen
dieser beistand beziehungsweise die
dieser schutz der wird natürlich primär
durch die vereinigten staaten
garantierte darüber sind sich alle im
bündnis bewusst unklar einschieben haben
wir noch mal kurz nachgeschaut das air
canada hat 66.000 mann unter waffen das
ist relativ bescheiden wenn man es im
weltmaßstab anschaut und und sieht wie
viele truppen die usa oder russland und
darauf ja es geht ja jetzt nicht in
erster linie um die truppen es geht vor
allem um das equipment wie man so schön
sagt die ausrüstung und die fähigkeiten
und die fähigkeiten die liegen gerade
was die lokale komponente anbelangt das
ist auch klar im nato-bündnis da gibt es
zwar frankreich noch und großbritannien
aber die liegen nun mal eindeutig mit
blick auf die abschreckungsfähigkeit und
die signalwirkung auch richtung in dem
fall moskau klar mit einem
überwältigenden gewicht auf der feier
auf der seite der vereinigten staaten
gibt es kein zweifel aber es ändert ja
nichts da dass es ungeheuer wichtig ist
man muss wissen wie das nato wird es
funktioniert wäre reden von beistand das
ist der berühmte artikel 5 der sagt ja
nicht der ist viel wichtiger verein in
seiner politischen signal wirkung wenn
dieser ausgerufen wird in der
bündnisfall ausgerufen würde wie 2001
terroranschläge angriff auf die
vereinigten staaten ist ein angriff auf
das gesamte bündnis heißt es heißt ja
noch nicht dass es so etwas wie einen
automatismus gibt dass jeder staat dann
eben auch militärisch sich beteiligt das
heißt noch nichts darüber wie viel jeder
einzeln einbringt das ist in erster
linie eine politische politische
solidaritätserklärung und deswegen ist
das politische signal das man
zusammensteht so wichtig weil es
voraussetzung ist auch für jeden
beschluss der normalerweise denn nun mal
in dem nato-bündnis aus einem zwischen
starte ich in meiner zwischenstaatlichen
organisation einstimmig gefällt werden
muss die frage ob polnische
kampfflugzeuge via rammstein via usa an
die ukraine geliefert werden sollen hat
auch in dieser pressekonferenz eine
rolle gespielt
die usa haben ja schon gesagt nein das
ist der bundeskanzler gefragt worden
hätte deutschland denn da überhaupt
mitgespielt bei schließlich kommt ja
deutschland spielmann rabenstein nochmal
in deutschland liegt wie haben sie seine
antwort interpretiert also ich meine
auch das war ja vollkommen erwartbar
wenn die usa nein sagen darf man nicht
erwarten dass die europäer ja sagen
würden in einer solch kritischen frage
und es ist eine frage von äußerster
brisanz diese lieferung von mix in
richtung über der der vorschlag puls
wird enorme sprengstoff und brisanz und
könnte ist der erste aspekt und punkt
der so ein bisschen also schon
signalisiert hier sind die einen bereit
weiter zu gehen als die anderen und
selbst die vereinigten staaten zögern
aus gutem grund weiter tut das aus gutem
grund und wir sind natürlich gut beraten
und werden auch mit sicherheit nicht auf
die idee kommen dass wir uns dafür stark
machen so lange dass die vereinigten
staaten nicht tun würden wir dürfen
nicht vergessen ganz konkret bedeutet
das dass hier die sorge der vereinigten
staaten
wir würden damit tatsächlich moskau
soweit provozieren dass man
diesen vorwurf der immer wieder wir
würden dann kriegsteilnehmer werden und
kriegspartei werden der würde ja
sozusagen auf eine neue stufe gehoben
werden denn diese maschinen diese
müssten rübergeflogen werden das müssen
erfahrene kampfpiloten machen das wären
amerikanische sein und das könnt ihr und
dafür das ist nicht vorstellbar in der
jetzigen situation man muss das ganz
realistisch sehen und deswegen an die
amerikaner hier klar und deutlich auf
die bremse getreten damit sind zwei ganz
zentrale forderungen der ukraine an den
westen an die nato abschlägig beschieden
worden die nato wird nicht mitarbeiten
oder garantieren oder durchsetzen wollen
dass es eine flugverbotszone über der
ukraine gibt und die nato wird auch
keine kampfflugzeuge liefern an die
ukraine wir wollen uns jetzt eine
stellungnahme werden sehen von heute
nacht des ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky
ukraine heute
haben wir wichtige neuigkeiten die
vereinigten staaten